[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the AI alignment podcast
I'm Lucas Perry today we have a
conversation with Steven Pinker and
Stuart Russell this episode explores the
historical and intellectual foundations
of AI how AI systems achieve or do not
achieve intelligence in the same way as
the human mind the benefits and risks of
AI over the short and long term and
finally whether super intelligent AI
poses an existential risk to humanity if
you're not currently following this
podcast series you can join us by
subscribing on Apple podcasts Spotify
SoundCloud or on whatever your favorite
podcasting app is by searching for
future of life our last episode was with
Sam Harris on global priorities if that
sounds interesting to you you can find
that conversation wherever you might be
following us I'd also like to echo two
announcements for the final time so if
you've been tuned in to the podcast
recently you can skip ahead just a bit
the first is that there is an ongoing
survey for this podcast where you can
give me feedback and voice your opinion
about content this goes a long way for
helping me to make the podcast valuable
for everyone this survey should only
come out once a year so this is a final
call for thoughts and feedback if you'd
like to voice anything you can find a
link for the survey about this podcast
in the description of wherever you might
be listening the second announcement is
that at the future of life Institute we
are in the midst of our search for the
2020 winner of the future of life award
the future of life award is a $50,000
prize that we give out to an individual
who without having received much
recognition at the time of their actions
has helped to make today dramatically
better than it may have been otherwise
the first two recipients of the future
of life award were Vasili arkhipov and
stanislav petrov - heroes of the nuclear
age both took actions at great personal
risk to possibly prevent an all-out
nuclear war the third recipient was dr.
Matthew meselson who spearheaded the
international ban on bioweapons right
now we're not sure who to give the 2020
future of life award to that's where you
come in if you know of an unsung hero
who has helped to avoid global
catastrophic disaster
or who
done incredible work to ensure a
beneficial future of life please head
over to the future of life award page
and submit a candidate for consideration
the link for that page is on the page
for this podcast or in the description
of wherever you might be listening if
your candidate is chosen you will
receive $3,000 as a token of our
appreciation
we're also incentivizing the search via
mi t--'s successful red balloon strategy
we're the first to nominate the winner
gets $3,000 as mentioned but there are
also tiered payouts we're the first to
invite the nomination winner gets $1,500
whoever first invited them gets 750
dollars whoever first invited them gets
375 dollars and so on you can find
details about that on the future of life
award page link in the description
Steven Pinker is a professor in the
Department of Psychology at Harvard
University he conducts research on
visual cognition psycho linguistics and
social relations he has taught at
Stanford and MIT and is the author of 10
books the language instinct how the mind
works the blank slate the better angels
of our nature the sense of style and
enlightenment now the case for reason
science humanism and progress Stewart
Russell is a professor of computer
science and holder of the Smith Zadeh
chair in engineering at the University
of California Berkeley he has served as
the vice chair of the World Economic
Forum's Council on AI and robotics and
as an adviser to the United Nations on
arms control he is an Andrew Carnegie
fellow as well as a fellow of the
Association for the Advancement of
artificial intelligence the Association
for Computing Machinery and the American
Association for the Advancement of
science
he is the author with Peter Norvig of
the definitive and universally acclaimed
textbook on AI artificial intelligence a
modern approach he is also the author of
human compatible artificial intelligence
and the problem of control and with that
here's our conversation with Steven
Pinker and Stuart Russell
so let's get started here then what are
the historical and intellectual
foundations upon which the ongoing AI
revolution is built well I would locate
them in the age of reason and the
Enlightenment when Thomas Hobbes said
reasoning is but reckoning reckoning in
the old-fashioned defensive calculation
about a century later even the major
styles of AI today the neural network
massively parallel interconnected system
that detrained and generalizes by
similarity as opposed to the more civil
crunching propositional good
old-fashioned AI both of those had at
abrasions or previews during the
Enlightenment when David Hume in the
empiricist or Association astre dition
said there are only three principles of
learning contiguity similarity and
cause-and-effect and he basically said
you get two things in quick succession
then when you get one of them you expect
the other and things that are similar to
it and then on the other side you have
liveness who thought of cognition as the
mechanical grinding of wheels and gears
and that what we now call the
manipulation of symbols so it does go
back but of course the actual progress
began in the 20th century with the ideas
of touring and Shannon and Weaver and
Norbert Wiener and then the history that
Stewart writes about in his textbook and
his recent book
I think I would like to add in a little
bit of ancient history as well just
because I think Aristotle not only
thought a lot about how human thinking
was organized and how it could be
correct or incorrect and how we could
make rational decisions he very clearly
describes a backward regression goal
planner and one of his pieces and his
work was incredibly influential and one
of the things he said is we deliberate
about means and not about ends I think
he says you know a doctor does not
choose whether to heal and so on and you
might disagree with that but I think
that that's being a pretty influential
thread in Western thinking for the last
two millennia or more that we kind of
take objectives is given and the purpose
of intelligence is to act in ways that
achieve your objectives that idea got
refined gradually so Aristotle talked
mainly about goals and logically
provable sequences of actions that would
achieve those goals
and then in the 17th and 18th centuries
want to give a shout-out to the French
and the Swiss so Pascal and Fermat and
on low and bernoulli brought in ideas of
rational decision making under
uncertainty and the weighing of
probabilities and the concept of utility
that Bernoulli introduced so that
generalized Aristotle's idea but he
didn't change the fundamental principle
that they took the objectives the
utilities has given just intrinsic
properties of a human being in a given
moment in AI we sort of went through the
same historical development except that
we did the logic stuff for the first 30
years or so roughly and then we did the
probability and decision Theory stuff
for the next 30 years I think we're in a
terrible state now because the vast
majority of the deep learning community
when you read their papers nothing is
cited before 2012
occasionally from time to time they'll
say things like for this problem you're
the learning algorithms that we have a
horribly inadequate and in future I
think we should direct some of our
research towards something that we might
call reasoning or knowledge as if no one
had ever thought of those things before
and they were the first person in
history to ever have the idea that
reasoning might be necessary for
intelligence yes I find this quite
frustrating and particularly frustrating
when students want to actually just
bypass the AI course altogether and go
straight to the deep learning course
because they just don't think AI is
necessary anymore indeed and
particularly galling to me given that in
the late 80s and 90s I was involved in a
debate over the applicability of they
weren't called deep learning models then
by multi-layer perceptrons or artificial
neural networks or connectionist
networks parallel distributed processing
networks and gary and palette prince and
Michael Ullman and I pointed out some of
the limitations of trying to achieve
intelligence even for simple linguistic
processes like forming the plural of a
noun or a past tense of the verb if the
only tool you had available was the
ability to associate features with
features without any symbol processing
so that debate went on it kind of
petered out but then one of the prime
tools in the neural network community
namely multi-layer networks trained by
era back propagation of course were what
got revived in 2012 and indeed there is
some amnesia for the history of the
debate back then which Gary Marcus's
survived for a modern era and would be
interesting to trace the idea not just
that there are rules or algorithms
whether they are from logic or
probability theory that an intelligent
agent can use the way a human pulls out
a smart phone but the idea that there is
nothing but rules or algorithms and
that's what an intelligent agent
consists of there is no ghost in the
machine no agent separate from the
mechanism and there I'm not sure if
Aristotle would have actually exercised
the ghost in the machine I think he did
have a notion of a soul the idea that
its rules all the way down and it's just
a mechanism probably has shallow roots
I think Hobbes probably could claim
credit for it and perhaps huma's well
that's an excellent point Steve it seems
like Abrahamic religions have kind of
given rise in part to this belief or
maybe the in expression of that belief
the kind of mind-body dualism the ghosts
in the machine
where the mind seems to be the
non-physical thing so it seems like
intelligence has had to go the same road
of life there used to be Alon VTOL or
some other spooky presupposed mechanism
for giving rise to life and so similarly
with intelligence it seems like we've
had to move from thinking that there was
a ghost in the machine that made the
things work - they're being rules all
the way down if you got something else
to add to that I think that'd be
interesting and my other two reactions
to what has been said so far are that
this point about computer science taking
the goal is given I think is important
and interesting and maybe we could
expand upon that a little bit and then
there's also the Stewart mentioned the
difference between AI and deep learning
and the students want to skip the AI and
just get straight to the deep learning
and that seems a little bit confusing to
me let me address the first part little
scribbles - over the second the notion
of dualism that there is a mechanism but
that's sitting on top of it there's an
immaterial agent or self or soul or AI
is enshrined in the Abrahamic religions
and at other religions but it has deep
intuitive roots there's a sense in which
we are all intuitively duelists Paul
bloom has made this argument in his book
des cartes baby and fortunately when we
deal with each other in everyday life we
don't treat each other like robots or
wind-up dolls but we assume that there
is an inner life that is much like ours
and we make sense of people's behavior
in terms of their beliefs and desires
which we don't conceptualize that
intuitively as neural circuitry
transforming patterns we just think that
there's a locus of consciousness which
is easy to think is separate from the
flesh that were made of especially since
this is a point made by the 19th century
British anthropologist Andrew Tyler that
there's actually a lot of empirical
evidence that supports dualism in our
everyday life like dreaming when you
dream you know your body's in bed the
whole time but there's some part of you
that's up and about in the
when you see your reflection in a mirror
or in stillwater
there's animated essence that seems to a
parted company with your body when
you're in a trance from a drug or a
fever it seems like there's a
out-of-body experience and so that we
and our bodies are not the same thing
and of course with death one moment a
person is walking around the next moment
the body is lifeless and it's natural to
think that it's lost some invisible
ingredient that it animated it while it
was alive today we know that this is
just the activity of the brain but in
terms of the experience available to a
person available for their intuition
dualism seems perfectly plausible and
it's one of the on one hand great
achievements of neuroscience to show
that a brain is capable of supporting
problem-solving and perception and
decision-making and of the computational
sciences for showing that intelligence
can be understood in terms of a physical
process of information and computation
and that goals the Aristotelian final
cause can be understood in terms of
control and cybernetics and feedback so
on the point that in computer science we
regard the objectives as fixed it's much
broader than just computer science I
mean if you look at von Neumann
Morgenstern and their characterizations
of rationality nowhere do they talk
about what is the process by which the
agent might rationally come by its
preferences the agent is always assumed
a priori to come with the Preferences
built in and the only constraint is that
those preferences be self-consistent so
that you can't be driven around circles
of intransitive preferences where you
simply COFF up money to go around around
the same circle the same thing I think
is true in control theory where the
objective is the cost function and you
design a controller that minimizes the
expected cost function which might be a
square of the distance from the desired
trajectory or whatever it might be same
in statistics where let's just assume
that there's a loss function there's no
discussion in statistics of what the
loss function should be or how the loss
function might change or anything like
that so this is something that pervades
many of the technological underpinnings
of the 20th century as far as I can tell
to some extent in developmental
psychology but I think in more
philosophy people really take seriously
the question of what goal should we have
is it moral for an agent to have such
and such as its objective and how could
we
for example teach an agent to have
different objectives and that gets you
into some very uncharted philosophical
waters about what is a rational process
that would lead an agent to have
different objectives at the end than it
did at the beginning given that if it
has different objectives at the end then
it can only expect that it won't be
achieving the objectives that it has at
the beginning so why would it embark on
a process that's going to result in
failure to achieve the objectives that
it currently has so that's sort of a
philosophical puzzle but it's a real
issue because in fact human beings do
change we're not born with the
preferences that we have as adults and
so there is a notion of plasticity that
absolutely has to be understood if we do
get this right indeed it is my point I
suspect we'll come to later when we talk
about potential risks of advanced
artificial intelligence that is the
extent to which having intelligence
implies that such a system would have
certain goals and probably Stuart and I
agree that the answer is no at least not
by definition precisely because what you
want and how to get what you want are to
logically independent questions of
course human famously said that reason
must be the slave of the passions by
which he didn't mean that we should just
surrender to our impulses and do
whatever feels good but it simply meant
is that reason itself can't specify the
goals that it tries to bring about that
those are exogenous and indeed I think
von Neumann and Morgenstern are often
misunderstood as saying that we must be
ruthlessly egotistical self-interested
maximizers whereas the goal that can be
programmed into us by evolution or by
culture could be that other people's
happiness is something that is part of
our utility function that is something
that making our choices consistent is
silent on
instead it's true that the ability to
reason doesn't by itself give you moral
goals including taking into account the
address of others but there is a long
tradition in moral philosophy of showing
how it doesn't take much to go from one
to the other because as soon as we care
about persuading others as soon as our
interests depend on how others treat us
then we can't get away with saying only
my interests count and yours don't cuz
I'm me and you're not because there is
no logical difference between me and you
so what kind of force - a kind of
impartiality
whereas whatever I insist on for me I've
got to grant to you my kind of golden
rule or a categorical imperative that
makes our interests interchangeable as
soon as were in discourse with one
another this is just to acknowledge us
to its point but to take it a few steps
further and how one deals with the
question of what are our goals to be the
other point you raise Lucas was on being
confused by my distinction between AI
and deep learning that's right I think
you're pointing to a confusion that
exists in the public mind in the media
and even in parts of the AI community ai
has always included machine learning as
a sub-discipline all the way back to
Turing's 1950 paper where he speculates
in fact that might be a good way to
build AI would be to start with a child
program and train it to be an adult
intelligent machine but there are many
other subfields of AI knowledge
representation reasoning planning
decision making under uncertainty
problem solving perception machine
learning is relevant to all of these
because they all involve processes that
can be improved through experience so
that's what we mean by machine learning
simply the improvement of performance
through experience and deep learning is
a technology that helps with that
process
if by itself as far as we can tell
doesn't have what is necessary to
produce general intelligence just to
pick one example the idea that human
beings know things seems so self-evident
that we hardly need to argue about it
but deep learning systems in a real
sense don't know things they can't
usefully acquire knowledge by reading a
book and then
go out and use that to design a radio
telescope which human beings arguably
can so it seems inevitable that if we're
going to make progress I mean sure we
take the advances that deep learning has
offered effectively what we've
discovered with deep learning is that
you can train more complicated circuits
than we previously would have guessed
possible using various kinds of
stochastic gradient descent and other
tricks I think it's true to say that
most people would not have expected that
you could build a thousand layer network
that was twenty thousand units wide
so it's got 20 million circuit elements
and simply put a signal in one end and
some data in the other and expect that
you're going to be able to train those
twenty million elements to represent the
complicated function that we're trying
to get it to learn so that was a big
surprise and that capability is opening
up all kinds of new frontiers in vision
in speech recognition language machine
translation and physical control and
robots among other things it's a
wonderful set of advances but it's not
the entire solution any more than group
theory is the entire solution to
mathematics there's lots of other
branches of mathematics that are
exciting and interesting and important
and you couldn't function without them
the same is true for AI so I think that
we're probably going to see even without
further major conceptual advances
another decade of progress in achieving
greater understanding of why deep
learning works on how to do it better
and all the various applications that we
can create using it but I think if we
don't go back and then try to
reintegrate all the other ideas of AI
we're going to hit a wall and so I think
the sooner we lose our obsession with
this new shiny thing the better I
couldn't agree more and indeed in some
ways we have hit the wall in a user of
theory or cortana or a
question-answering system often gets
frustrated by the fact that it pretty
much makes associations to individual
words and very often has a shallow
understanding of even the syntax of the
sentence if you ask of Google or Siri
can you show me music players without a
camera it will give you a long list of
music players and they
cameras but even the syntax of X without
y or what are some fast-food restaurants
that are not McDonald's and you get a
list of McDonald's it's not that hard to
bump into the limitations of systems
that still for all their sophistication
are being trained upon associations of
very local elements can indeed I agree
surprisingly learn higher-order
combinations of those elements but still
despite the name deep learning are
shallow in the sense that they don't
build up a knowledgebase of knowing what
are the objects who did what to whom and
accessing them from various routes yeah
my favorite example I'm not sure if it's
apocryphal is you say to Siri call me an
ambulance and Siri says ok from now on
I'll call you an ambulance yeah uh-huh
you know a Marx Brothers movie there's
the sequence call me a taxi ok you're a
taxi I don't know if that's an urban
legend based on the Marx Brothers movie
or whether life is imitating art
Stephen I really appreciated and liked
that point about dualism and
intelligence I think it points in really
interesting directions around identity
in the self which we don't have time to
get into here but I did appreciate that
so moving on ahead here to what extent
do you both see AI systems as achieving
intelligence in the same way or not as
the human mind does what kinds of
similarities are there or differences
this is a really interesting question
and we could spend the whole two hours
just talking about this so by artificial
intelligence I am going to take it that
we mean not deep learning but the full
range of techniques that AI researchers
have developed over the years so some of
them for example logical reasoning were
developed you know going back to
Aristotle and other Greek philosophers
who developed formal logic to model
human thinking so it's not surprising
that when we build programs that do
logical reasoning we are in some sense
capturing one aspect of human reasoning
capability and then in the 80s as I
mentioned a I developed reasoning under
uncertainty and then later on refining
that with notions of causality as well
particularly in the work of due to poll
the differences are really because AI
and cognitive science separated
probably sometime in the 60s I think
before that there wasn't really a clear
distinction between whether you were
doing AI or whether you were doing
cognitive science it was very much
thought that if you could get a program
to do anything that we think of as
requiring intelligence with a human then
you were in some sense exhibiting a
possible theory of how the human does it
or even you would make introspective
claims and say look I've now shown that
this theory of intelligence really works
but fairly soon people said look this is
not really scientific if you want to
make a claim about how the human mind
does something you have to base it on
real psychological experimentation with
human subjects and that's distinct from
the engineering goal of AI which is
simply to produce programs that
demonstrate certain capabilities so for
most of the last 50 60 years these two
fields have grown further and further
apart I think now partly because of deep
learning and partly because of other
work for example in probabilistic
programming we can start to do things
that humans do that we couldn't do
before and so it becomes interesting
again to ask well are humans really
somewhat Bayesian and are they doing
these kinds of Bayesian symbolic
probabilistic program learning that for
example Josh Tenenbaum was proposing or
are they doing something else for
example Geoff Hinton is pretty adamant
that as he puts it symbols or the
luminiferous ether of AI by which he
means that there is simply something
that we imagined and they have no
physical reality whatsoever in the human
mind
I find this a little hard to believe and
you have to wonder if symbols don't
exist
why are almost all deep learning
applications aimed at recognizing the
symbolic category to which an object
belongs and I haven't heard an answer
yet from the deep learning community
about why that is but it's also clear
that AI systems are doing things that
have no resemblance to human cognition
when you look at what alphago is
actually doing part of it is that sort
of perception like ability to look at a
position and get a sense to use an
anthropomorphic term of its potential
for a winning for white or for black and
perhaps that part is human-like and
naturally it's incredibly good it's
probably better at recognizing the
potential position directly with no
deliberation whatsoever than a human is
but the other part of what alphago does
is completely non-human it's considering
sequences and moves from the current
state that run all the way to the end of
the game so part of it is searching in a
tree which could go 40 or 50 or possibly
more moves into the future and then from
the end of the tree it then plays a
random game all the ways the end and
sees who wins that game and this is
nothing like what human beings do when
humans are reasoning about a game like
go war chess first of all we are
thinking about it in multiple levels of
abstraction so we're thinking about the
liveness of a particular group we're
thinking about control of a particular
region of territory on the board we're
thinking well if I give up control of
this territory then I can trade it for
capturing his group over there so this
kind of reasoning simply doesn't happen
in alphago at all we reason back from
goals in chess you said perhaps I could
trap his queen let me see if I can come
up with a move that blocks this exit for
the Queen so we reasoned backwards from
goals and no chess program and no go
program does that kind of reasoning and
the reason humans do this is because the
world is incredibly complicated and in
different circumstances different kinds
of cognitive processing are efficient
and effective in producing good
decisions quickly and that's
a real issue for human intelligence
right if we didn't have to worry about
computation that we would just set up
the giant unknown partially observable
Markov decision process at the universe
solve it and then we would take the
first action in the virtually infinite
strategy tree that solves that
MDP and then we would observe the next
percept we would update all our beliefs
about the universe and we would refold
the universe and that's how we would
proceed and we would have to do that
sort of roughly every millisecond to
control the muscles in our body but we
don't do anything like that and all of
the different kinds of mental
capabilities that we have are deployed
in this amazingly fluid way to get us
through the complexity of the real world
and we are so far away in AI from
understanding how to do that but when I
see people say we're just going to scale
up our deep learning systems by another
three orders of magnitude M will be more
intelligent than humans I just smile
yeah I'd like to compliment some of
those observations it is true that in
the early days of both artificial
intelligence and cognitive psychology
they were driven by some of the same
players from Symon and Alan dual can be
credited as among the founders of AI and
founders of cognitive psychology
likewise Marvin Minsky and John McCarthy
when I was an undergraduate I kind of
caught the tail end of the what was
sometimes called the cognitive
revolution and it's just exhilarating
after the dominance of psychology by
behaviorism which forbade any talk of
mentalistic concepts you weren't allowed
to talk about memories or plans or goals
or ideas or rules because they were
considered to be unscientific then the
whole concept of computation
domesticated those mentalistic terms and
opened up a huge space of hypotheses one
of the rules by which we understand and
formulate sentences the project that
done Noam Chomsky initiated how can we
model human knowledge in terms of a
semantic network that Minsky and Collins
and quillian and others developed how do
we make sense
foresight and planning and
problem-solving the duel and Simon
pioneered there's a lot of
back-and-forth between a
cognitive science just because we were
first being exposed to the very idea
that intelligence could be understood in
mechanistic terms and there was that
flow of hypotheses from computer science
that we then tested in possible models
ideally couldn't even frame you couldn't
even articulate before there was the
language of computation such as what is
the capacity of human short-term memory
or what are the search algorithms by
which we explore a problem space these
just would have been unintelligible to
the era of behaviorism there was a lot
of back and forth it caught the
attention of philosophers like Hilary
Putnam and then later Dan Dennett who
noted that the ideas from this hybrid of
cognitive psychology and artificial
intelligence were answering deep
questions about what mental entities
consist of mainly information processing
states what intelligence consists of and
there's a lot of back-and-forth
exfilling you into the 70s when I was a
graduate student and even the 80s and
theythey founding of centers for
cognitive science funded by the sloan
foundation there was also in a more
practical setting a lot of openness in
the companies that hired artificial
intelligence researchers AT&T Bell Labs
which was a scientific powerhouse before
the breakup of AT&T bolt Beranek and
Newman and Cambridge which then became
part of Verizon but I used to go over as
a grad student and hear talks in
artificial intelligence there I don't
know if this is a apocryphal history by
Xerox Palo Alto Research Center's where
I was a consultant was so open that
according to legend Steve Jobs walked in
saw the first computer with a graphic
user interface and a mouse and windows
and icon and walked out and stole the
ideas the luisa and the Macintosh and
then companies got proprietary many of
the researchers and companies no longer
published in peer-reviewed journals in
psychology the way they used to and the
two cultures I think started to drift
apart since hypotheses from computer
science and artificial intelligence are
just hypotheses there is the question of
whether the best engineering solution to
solve a problem is the one that the
brain uses and there's the obvious
objection that the hardware is radically
different that the brain is massively
parallel and noisy and stochastic and
computers are serial and deterministic
and then with that led in part to that
backlash in the 80s when perceptrons and
artificial neural networks were revived
there's a lot of skepticism about the
more symbolic approaches to artificial
intelligence then itself revived to now
in me of deep learning era in answering
the question what are ways in which
human minds differ from AI systems again
it depends on the AI system assess to
had pointed out but I think if both of
us would agree that the easy equation of
deep learning networks with human
intelligence is unwarranted that a lot
of the walls that deep learning is
hitting come about because despite the
noisy parallel elements the brain is
made of we do emulate a kind of simple
processing architecture where we can be
taught explicit of propositions and that
human intelligence doesn't make use of
these symbols in addition to these
massively parallel associative networks
I can't help but mention I've known Jeff
Engine since we were both postdocs he
contend himself early in his career
provided a kind of refutation of that
position that Stewart cited that symbols
are just luminiferous ether they just
found myth but early on and Jeff and I
have noted this with each other we've
kind of switched sides and a couple of
debates and there was a debate over the
nature of mental imagery in the late 70s
which Jeff and I were opposite sides and
he was the simple guy and I was the kind
of analog parallel network guy and
Hinton himself showed that even our
understanding of a 3-dimensional object
depends on the symbolic way in which we
mentally represented something as simple
as magining a cube poised on one of its
vertices with the other vertex
immediately above it if you ask people
okay point to the other vertices they
are stymied their imagery fails they
often leave out a couple of vertices but
if instead you describe it to them as
instead of a cube tilted on its diagonal
axis described it as say two diamonds
that are tilted one about the other or
two tripods joined by a zigzag ring all
of a sudden they get the correct answer
and so even their visualization depends
critically on how they mentally describe
it to themselves with symbols this is an
argument that Jeff injured himself made
in 1979 and I think he may have
forgotten his own
powerful example I think another area
where the burning is clearly not
capturing the human capacity for
learning is just in the efficiency of
learning I remember in the mid 80s going
to some classes in psychology at
Stanford and there were people doing
machine learning ban and they were very
proud of their results and somebody
asked Gordon Bower how many examples two
humans need to learn this kind of thing
and Gordon said what sometimes two
usually one and this is generally true
right if you look for a picture book
that has one to two million pictures of
giraffes to teach children what a
giraffe is you won't find one picture
books that tell children what you're us
I have one picture of a giraffe one
picture of an elephant and the child
gets it immediately even though it's a
very crude cartoonish drawing of a
giraffe or an elephant they never have a
problem recognizing giraffes and
elephants for the rest of their lives
deep learning systems are needing you
know even for these relatively simple
concepts thousands tens of thousands
millions of examples and the idea within
deep learning seems to be that well the
way we're going to scale up to more
complicated things like learning how to
write an email to ask for a job is that
we'll just have billions or trillions
and examples and then we'll be able to
learn really really complicated concepts
but of course the universe just doesn't
contain enough data for the machine to
learn direct mappings from perceptual
inputs or really actually perceptual
input histories to imagine your entire
video record of your life and that feeds
into a decision about what to do next
and you have to learn that mapping as a
supervised learning problem
it's not even funny how unfeasible that
is the longer the deep learning
community persists in this the worse the
pain is going to be when their heads
bang into the wall when there aren't
discussions of super intelligence based
on extrapolating deep learning I'm often
puzzled as to what people could possibly
need so imagine an AI system in the
future that's going to solve the problem
of Middle East peace or a cure cancer it
kind of implies that we could train it
with 60 million diseases and their cures
and it will
extract the patterns and therefore be
able to cure the new disease that we
presented that's what would have to be
if it really were an extrapolation of
the current techniques needless to say
let alone in solving global warming or
pandemics or at least in peace there
aren't going to be 60 million problems
with their correct answers that can
provide a supervised learning training
set so human children and humans are
generally capable of one-shot learning
or you said we can learn via seeing one
instance of a thing whereas machine
learning today is trained up via very
very large data sets can you explain
what the actual perceptual difference is
going on there it seems like for
children they see a giraffe and they can
develop a bunch of higher-order
facts about the giraffe like that is tan
and has spots and the long neck and
horns and other kinds of higher-order
things whereas machine learning systems
may be doing something else so could you
explain that difference yeah I think you
actually captured it pretty well the
human child is able to recognize the
object not as 20 million pixels
including let's not forget all the
pixels of the background so many of
these learning algorithms are actually
learning to recognize the background not
the object at all they're really picking
up on spurious regularities that happen
in the way the images are being captured
but the human child immediately
separates the figure from the
backgrounds as okay it's the figure
that's being called you off and
recognizes the higher-level properties
okay it's a quadruped head relatively
large but most distinguishing
characteristic as you say is the very
long neck plus the way it's hide is
colored probably most kids might not
even notice the horns and I'm not even
sure do all Duras have the horns or just
the males or just the adults I don't
know the answer to that so I wasn't
paying much attention to all those
images this carries over to many many
other situations including in things
like planning where if we observe
someone carrying out a successful
behavior that one example combined with
our prior knowledge is typically enough
for us to get the general idea of how to
do that thing and this prior knowledge
is absolutely crucial I just information
theoretically you can't learn from one
example reliably unless you bring to
bear a great deal of prior knowledge and
this is completely absent in deep
learning systems in two ways all right
so one is they don't have any prior
knowledge and two is some of the prior
knowledge is specifically about the
thing you are trying to predict so here
we're trying to predict the category of
an animal and we already have a great
deal of prior knowledge about what it
means to belong to a category of animals
for example who owns you is not an
attribute that the child would need to
know or care about if you said what kind
of animal is this and deep learning
systems have no ability to include or
exclude any input attribute on the basis
of its relevance to what it's trying to
predict because they know nothing about
what it is you're trying to predict and
if you think about it that doesn't make
any sense right if I said okay I want
you to learn to predict predicate P 1 2
7 9 a a on again you you loads and loads
of examples and now you've got a perfect
predictor for P 1 2 7 9 a but you have
absolutely no use for it
because P 1 2 7 9 a doesn't connect to
anything else in your cognition so
you've learned a completely useless
predictor because you know nothing about
the thing that we're trying to predict
so it seems like it's broken in several
really really important ways and I would
say probably the absence of prior
knowledge or of any memes to bring to
bear prior knowledge on the learning
process is the most crucial indeed in
going back to our conversation on how
basic principles of intelligence that
govern the design of intelligent systems
provide hypotheses that then can be
tested within psychology I think what
Stewart has identified is really the
nature-nurture problem in cognition
namely what are the innate constraints
that govern children's hypotheses as
they try to make sense of the world and
some famous answers include Chomsky's
universal grammar when it comes to
acquiring language the idea from my
colleague Susan Kerry and Elizabeth's
Pelkey in different formulations that
children might have some prior concept
of a physical object whose parts move
together and it persists over time that
follows continuous spatio-temporal
trajectories the idea that there are
agents or minds
have beliefs and desires maybe or maybe
not the concept of a living thing or of
an artifact and that these radically cut
down the search space of hypotheses so
that it isn't at the level of pixels and
all there are logically possible
combinations of course they challenge in
the science is how do you specify the
innate constraints the prior knowledge
so that they aren't obviously too
specific given what we know about the
plasticity of human cognition the
extreme example being delayed philosophy
Jerry Fodor suggestion that all concepts
are in age including trombone and
doorknob carburetor well hard to swallow
but between that and the deep learning
architecture in which the only thing
that's an ADA are the pixels the
convolutional network that allows for
translational invariance and then the
connections in the network there's
probably an interesting middle ground
that defines the central research
question really in cognitive development
I don't think you have to believe in
extensive innate structures in order to
believe that pry knowledge is really
really important for learning I would
guess that some aspects of our cognition
are innate and one of them is probably
that the world contains things and
that's really important because if you
just think about the brain as circuits
so circuit languages don't have things
as first-class entities
whereas first-order logical languages or
programming languages do have things as
first of all somebody's and that's a
really important distinction even if you
believe that nothing is innate the point
is how does everything that you have
perceived up to now affect your ability
to learn the next thing one argument is
everything you've received up to now is
simply data and somehow magically we
have access to all of our past
perceptions and then you're just
training a function from that whole lot
to the next thing to do or how to
interpret the next object that doesn't
make much sense presumably the
experience you have from birth or even
pre birth onwards is converted into
something and one argument is converted
into something like knowledge and then
that knowledge is brought to bear on
learning problems for example to even
decide what are the relevant aspects of
the input for predicting
category membership of this thing and
the other view would be that in the deep
learning community they would say
probably something like the accumulation
of features if you imagine a giant
recurrent neural network in the hidden
layers of the recurrent neural network
over years and years and years exception
you're building up internal
representations features which then can
perhaps simplify the learning of the
next concept that you need to learn and
there's probably some truth in that too
and absolutely having a library of
features that are generally useful for
predicting and decision-making and
planning and our entire vocabulary and I
think this is something that people
often miss our vocabulary our language
is not just something we use to
communicate with each other
it's an enormous resource for
simplifying the world in the right ways
to make the next thing we need to know
where the next thing we need to do
relatively easy right so imagine you
decide the age of 12 I want to
understand the physical laws that
control universe the fact that we have
in our vocabulary something like doing a
PhD makes it much more feasible to
figure out what your plan is going to be
to achieve this objective if you didn't
have that and if you didn't have all the
pieces of doing a PhD like take a course
read a book this library of words and
action primitives at all these levels of
abstraction is a resource without which
you would be completely unable to
formulate plans of any length or any
likelihood of success and this is
another area where current AI systems I
would say generally not just deep
learning we lack a real understanding of
how to formulate these hierarchies and
acquire this vocabulary like and then
how to deploy it in a seamless way so
that we're always managing to function
successfully in the real world I'm
basically just as confused about I guess
intelligence as anyone else so the
difference it seems to me between the
machine learning system and the child
who one-shot learns the giraffe is the
the child brings into this learning
scenario this knowledge that you guys
are talking about that they understand
that the world is populated by things
and that there
minds and some other ideas about 3d
objects and perception but a core
difference seems to be something like
symbols and the ability to manipulate
symbols is this right or is it wrong and
what are symbols and effective symbol
manipulation made of that would be a
limitation of the so-called deep
learning systems which are a subset of
machine learning which is a subset of
artificial intelligence it's certainly
not true that AI systems don't
manipulate symbols indeed that's what
classical AI systems trading
manipulation of propositions
implementation of versions of logical
inference or of cause-and-effect
reasoning those can certainly be
implemented in AI systems have just gone
out of fashion with a deep learning
craze but they don't learn those symbols
right like we give them the symbols from
they manipulate them you could make an
argument that the basic architecture of
the system almost by definition can't be
learned him you can't learn something
with nothing so there's got to be some
elementary information processes some
formats of data representation some
basic ways of transforming one
representation to another that are just
hardwired into the architecture of the
system and that can include and it's an
open empirical question in the case for
the human brain whether it includes
variables for objects and minds or
living things or artifacts or if those
are kind of scaffolded one on top of the
other with experience but it's just
crucial to note that there's nothing in
principle that prevents AI systems from
doing that many of them do but that's
just at least for now fallen out of
fashion
there is the precedent for generating
new symbols both in the per blastic
programming literature and in the
inductive logic programming literature
so predicate invention is a very
important reason for doing inductive
logic programming but I agree with Steve
that it's an open question as to whether
the basic capacity to have a news symbol
based representations in the brain he is
innate or as it learned there's very
anecdotal evidence about what happens to
children who are not brought up among
other human beings I think those
anecdotes suggest that they don't become
simple using in the same way so it might
be that the process of developing symbol
using capabilities in the brain is
enormous Lee aided by the
that we grow up in the presence of
symbol using entities namely our parents
and family members and community and of
course act leads you to then a
chicken-and-egg problem so you'd have to
argue in that case that early humans or
pre humans had much more rudimentary
symbol like capabilities some animals
have the ability to refer to different
phenomena or objects with different
signs different kinds of sounds that
some new world monkeys have for example
for a snake and for Puma but they're not
able to do the full range of things that
we do with symbols you could argue that
the symbol using capability developed
over hundreds of thousands of years and
the unaided human mind doesn't come with
it built-in but because we're usually
bathed in symbol using activity around
us we are able to quickly pick it up I
don't know what the truth is but it
seems very clear that this kind of
capability for example gives you the
ability to generalize so much faster
than you can with circuits so just to
give a particular example of the rules
ago we talked about earlier the rules
are go apply the same rule at every time
step in the game and it's the same rule
at every square in the game except
around the edges and if you have what we
call first order capability meaning you
can have Universal quantifiers or in
programs you think of these as loops you
can say very quickly for every square on
the board if you have a piece on there
and it's surrounded by the enemy then
it's dead so crude approximation to how
things look and go but it's roughly
right in a circuit you can't say that
because you don't have the ability to
say for every square so you have to have
a piece of circuit for each square so
you've got 361 copies of the rule in
each of those copies has to be learned
separately and this is one of the things
that we do with convolutional neural
networks convolutional neural network
has the universal quantifier over the
input space built into it so it's a kind
of cheating and as far as we know the
brain doesn't have that type of weight
sharing so the key aspect is not just
the physical structure of the
convolution
network which has this repeating local
receptive fields on each different part
of the retina so to speak but that we
also insist that the weights for each of
those local receptive fields are copied
across all receptive fields in the
retina so there aren't millions of
separate weights that are trained
there's only a few sometimes even just a
handful of weights that are trained and
then the code makes sure that those are
effectively copied across the entire
retina and the brain I don't think has
any way to do that so it's doing
something else to achieve this kind of
rapid generalization all right so now
with all of this context and
understanding about intelligence and its
origins today in 2020 AI is beginning to
proliferate and is occupying a lot of
new cycles what particular important
changes to human society does the rise
and proliferation of AI signal and how
do you view it in relation to the
agricultural and industrial revolutions
I'm gonna give a kind of a meta answer
to the question which is that we should
keep in mind how spectacularly ignorant
we are of the future even the relatively
near future experts in super forecasting
studied by Phil tetlock pretty much the
best in the world go down to about
chance after about 5 years out and we
know looking at predictions of the
future from the past often how ludicrous
they can be both in under predicting
technological changes and in over
predicting a book by Bill Gates called
the road ahead in 1993 said virtually
nothing about the internet and there's a
kind of a sport of looking at science
fiction movies and spotting the
ludicrous anachronism such as the fact
that in 2001 a Space Odyssey they were
using typewriters apparently they had
suspended animation and trips to Jupiter
but they hadn't invented the word
processor to say nothing of the fact
that all of the women in the movie were
secretaries so we should just
acknowledge that it would be
extraordinarily difficult to predict and
there's a systematic reason namely that
the future depends on technological
developments but also on people's
reaction to the developments there are
reactions to the reactions and the
reactions to the reactions to the
reactions they're seven and a half
billion of us and so we just have to
acknowledge that there's a lot that
we're going to get wrong
I think it's safe to say that a lot of
tasks that involve physical manipulation
like stocking shelves and driving trucks
are going to be automated and societies
will have to deal with the possibility
of radical changes in employment and
Stewart talks about those in his book we
don't even really know for sure whether
the job market is going to be flexible
enough to just pick up the automated
jobs and create new jobs always at the
front here of what machines can't yet do
or whether they'll be massive
unemployment that will require economic
adjustments such as a universal basic
income or a government-sponsored service
to ameliorate the extent to which
high-level decision making that is
policy diplomacy scientific hypothesis
testing will be replaced by an AI I
think is impossible to predict although
closer to the replacement of truck
drivers by autonomous vehicles certainly
as AI as a tool will explode in
usefulness and science in business and
technology and in every walk of life
I think all those things are true and I
agree that our general record of
forecasting has been pretty dismal I am
smiling as he was talking cuz I was
remembering ray kurzweil recently saying
how proud he was that he had predicted
the self-driving car I think was in 1962
something like that and possibly wasn't
aware that the first self-driving car
was driving on the freeway in 1987
before he even thought to predict that
such a thing might happen if I had to
say you know in the next decade if you
said roughly speaking that what happened
in the 2010s was primarily that visual
perception became very crudely feasible
for machines when it wasn't before and
that's already having huge impact
including in self-driving cars I would
say that language understanding at least
in a simplified sense will become
possible in this decade I think it'll be
a combination of deep learning with
horriblest ik programming with Bayesian
and symbolic methods that will open up
enormous areas of activity to machines
where they simply couldn't go before and
some of that will be very
straightforward job replacement you know
for call center workers most of what
they do I think could be automated by
systems that are able to understand
their conversations the role of the
smart speaker the Alexa or Cortana or
Siri or whatever will radically change
and will enable AI systems to actually
understand your life to a much greater
extent
one of the reasons that Siri and Cortana
elects are not very useful to me because
they just don't understand anything
about my life the call me an ambulance
example illustrates that if I got a text
message saying Johnny's in the hospital
with a broken arm well if it doesn't
understand that Johnny is possibly my
cat or possibly my son or possibly my
great-grandfather and there's Johnny you
live nearby or in my house or on another
continent then it hasn't the faintest
idea what to do or even whether I care
it's only really through language
understanding I doubt that we're going
to be filling these things full of first
order logic assertions that we will type
into our AI system so it's only through
language that it's going to be able to
acquire the knowledge that it needs to
be a useful assistant to an individual
or corporation so having that language
capability will I think open up whole
new areas for AI to be useful to
individuals and also to take jobs from
people and I'm not able to predict what
else we might be able to do with AI
systems that understand language but it
has to have a huge impact is there
anything else that you guys would like
to add in terms of where AI is at right
now where it'll be in the near future
and the benefits and risks it will pose
I could point to a few things that are
already happening there's a lot of
discussion about the negative impacts on
women and minorities from algorithms
that inadvertently pick up on biases in
society so we saw an example of Amazon's
hiring algorithm that rejected any
resume that had the word woman's in it
and I think that serious but I think the
AI community we still not completely
woke and there's a lot of consciousness
raising that needs to happen but I think
technically that problem is manageable
and I think one interesting thing that's
occurring is that we're starting to
develop an understanding not just of the
machine learning algorithm but of the
socio technical context in which that
machine learning is embedded and
modeling that social technical context
allows you to predict whether the use of
that algorithm will have negative
feedback kinds of consequences or it'll
be vulnerable to certain kinds of
selection bias in the input data and so
on
deep fake surveillance manipulation
that's another big area and then
something I'm very concerned about is
the use of AI for autonomous weapons
this is another area where we fight
against media stereotypes so when the
media talk about autonomous weapons they
invariably have a picture of a
terminator always and I tell journalists
I'm not going to talk to you if you put
a picture of a terminator in the article
and they always say well I don't have
any control over that that's a different
part of the newspaper and it always
happens anyway and the reason that's a
problem is because then everyone thinks
oh well this is science fiction we don't
have to worry about this because this is
science fiction and you know I've heard
the Russian ambassador to the UN in
Geneva say well why are we even
discussing these things because this is
science fiction it's 20 or 30 years in
the future oh and by the way I have some
of these weapons if you'd like to buy
them the reality is that many militaries
around the world are developing these
companies are selling them there's a
Turkish arms company STM selling a
device which is basically the slaughter
bot from the slaughter BOTS movie so
it's a small drone with onboard
explosives and they advertise it as
capable of tracking and autonomously
attacking human beings based on video
signatures and/or face recognition the
Turkish government has announced that
they're going to be using those against
the Kurds in Syria sometime this year so
we'll see if it happens but there's no
doubt that this is not science fiction
and it's very real and it's going to
create a new kind of weapon of mass
destruction because if it's autonomous
it doesn't need to be supervised and if
it doesn't need to be supervised then
you can launch them by the million and
then you have something with the same
effect as a nuclear weapon but much
cheaper much easier to proliferate with
much less collateral damage and all the
rest of it I think in all of these
discussions it's critical to not fall
prey to a status quo biased and assume
that the problems of the future
technology are compared with an
idealized problem-free present so in the
case of bias we know that humans are
horribly biased and not only biased
against particular genders or ethnic
groups or sexual orientations but just
that we
make judgments that can easily be
outperformed by even simple algorithms
like a linear regression formula so that
we should just remember that our
benchmark in talking about the
accuracies or inaccuracies of AI
prediction algorithms has to be the
human and that's often a pretty low bar
when it comes to bias of course a system
that's trained on a sample and Sun
represented and is not a particularly
intelligent system and of course going
back to the idea that we have to
distinguish the goals we want to achieve
from the intelligence that achieves them
if the goal is to overcome past
inequities then by definition we don't
want to simply make selections now to
replicate the statistical distribution
of women and minorities in the past our
goal is to rectify some of those
inequities and so the problem in a
system that replicates them is not that
it's not intelligent enough but that
we've given it the wrong goal it comes
to weapons here - we've got to compare
the potential harm of intelligent weapon
systems with the stupendous harm of dumb
weapon systems aerial bombardment
artillery search and destroying
mechanisms
tank battles kill people literally by
the millions I think there's been
insufficient attention to a battleground
that use smarter weapons how it would
compare against what we've tolerated for
centuries simply because that's what we
have come to accept it's been
fantastically destructive well
ultimately of course we want to do is
make use of any weapons less and less
likely and as I've written about that
has been the general trend in the last
75 years
fortunately yeah I think there is some
truth on that when I first got the email
from Human Rights Watch so they began a
campaign it was back in 2013 to argue
for a treaty banning autonomous weapons
Human Rights Watch came into existence
because of the awful things that human
soldiers do and now they say no no human
soldiers are great it's the machines we
need to worry about and I found that a
little bit odd to me the argument about
whether the weapons will inadvertently
violate human rights in ways that human
soldiers don't or sort of accidentally
kill people in ways that we are getting
better at avoiding I don't think
that's the issue I think it's
specifically the weapon of mass
destruction property that autonomous
weapons have that for example machine
guns done there's a hundred million or
more Kalashnikov rifles in private hands
in the world if all those weapons got up
one morning by themselves and started
shooting anyone they could see that
would be a big chunk of the human race
gone but they don't do that each of them
has to be carried by a person and if you
want to put a million of them into the
field you need another ten million
people to feed and train those million
soldiers and to transport them and
protect them and all that stuff and
that's why we haven't seen very large
scale death from all those hundred
million Kalashnikovs even carpet bombing
which i think nowadays would be regarded
as indiscriminate and therefore a
violation of international law and I
think even during the Second World War
people argued that no you can't go and
bomb cities but once the Germans started
to do it than there was escalating
rounds the retaliation and people lost
to a sense of what was a civilized and
what was an uncivilized act of war but
even the blitz against Great Britain as
far as I know killed only 350 and 60,000
people even though it hit dozens and
dozens of cities but literally one
truckload of autonomous weapons can kill
a million people an interesting fact
about world war two is that for every
person who died between a thousand and
ten thousand bullets were fired so just
killing people with bullets on average
in World War two cost you let's say that
take a geometric mean three thousand
bullets which is actually about a
thousand dollars at current prices but
you could build a lethal autonomous
weapon for a lot less than that and even
if they had a twenty five percent
success rate in finding and killing
human it's much cheaper than the bullet
let alone the guns and the aircraft and
all the rest of it so as a way of
killing very very large numbers of
people it's incredibly cheap and
incredibly effective it can also be
selected so you can kill just the kind
of people you want to get rid of and it
seems to me that we just don't need
another weapon of mass destruction with
all of these extra characteristics
we've got rid of to some extent
biological and chemical weapons we're
trying to get rid of nuclear weapons and
injured
another one that's in arguably much
worse we used to be a step in the wrong
direction well you asked also let the
benefits of artificial intelligence
which I think could be stupendous and
they would include elimination of
drudgery and boring and dangerous jobs
that no one really likes to do like
stocking shelves and making beds and
mining coal and picking fruit there
could be a potential enormous bonanza in
all of those things that humans want
being done without human pain and labour
and boredom and danger
raising the problem of how we support
people if such people exist who have
nothing to do but that's I think a minor
economic problem compared to the
spectacular advance in eliminating human
drudgery also there are a lot of jobs
pledges the care of elderly people
lifting patients onto toilets allowing
people to reach things from upper
shelves that allow them to live at home
instead of being warehoused in nursing
homes where the potential for human
flourishing is also spectacular and as I
mentioned there are a lot of cases of
human judgement that are so error prone
that they can already be replaced by
simple algorithms that we had more
intelligent algorithms there's the
potential of much less waste much less
error far fewer accidents an obvious
example there being the million a
quarter people killed in traffic
accidents that could be terrifically
reduced if we ever had autonomous
vehicles that were affordable and
widespread a core of this is that all
the problems that humanity faces simply
require intelligence to solve them
essentially and if we're able to solve
the problem of how to make intelligent
machines then our problems will evermore
and continuously become automatable by
machine systems so Stuart do you have
anything else to add here in terms of
existential hope and benefits to
complement what Steve just contributed
before we pivot into existential risk
yeah there is an argument going around
and I think Mark Zuckerberg said it
pretty clearly an aura at SUNY and other
various other people have said basically
the same thing and is usually put this
way if you're against AI then you are
against better medical decisions or
reducing medical errors or safer cars
and so on and this is I think just a
ridiculous argument so first of all
people who are concerned about the risks
of AI are not again
i right that's like arguing pure a
nuclear engineer and you are concerned
about the possibility of a design flaw
that would lead to a meltdown you're
against electricity no you're not
against electricity you're just against
millions of people dying for no reason
and you want to fix the problem and the
same argument I think is true about
those who are concerned about the risk
of AI say I didn't have any benefits we
wouldn't be having this discussion at
all no one would be investing any money
no one would have put their lives and
careers into working on the capabilities
of AI and the whole point would be moot
so of course AI will have benefits but
if you don't address the risks you won't
get the benefits because the technology
will be rejected or we won't even have a
choice to reject it and if you look at
what happened with nuclear power I think
it's really an object lesson nuclear
power could and still can produce quite
cheap electricity so I have a house in
France and most electricity parts comes
from nuclear power and is very cheap and
very reliable and it also doesn't
produce a lot of carbon dioxide but
because of Chernobyl the nuclear
industry has been literally decimated by
which I mean reduced by a factor of 10
or more and so we didn't get the
benefits because we didn't pay enough
attention to the risks the same holds
with AI so the benefits of AI in the
long run I would argue are pretty
unlimited and you know medical errors
and safer cars that's all nice but it's
a tiny tiny footnote in what can be done
is Steve already mentioned the
elimination of drudgery and repetitive
work it's easy for us intellectuals to
talk about that we've never really
engaged in a whole lot of it but for
most of the human race but most of
recorded history people with power money
have used everybody else as robots to
get what they want whether we've been
using them as military robots or
agricultural robots or factory robots
we've been using people as robots and if
you had gone back to the early under
gatherer days and written some
science-fiction and you said you know
what in the future people will go into
big square buildings thousands of feet
long with no windows and they'll do the
same thing a thousand times a day and
that'll go back the next day and do the
same thing another thousand times and
they're going to do that for thousands
of days until they're practically dead
the audience the readers in science
fiction in 20,000 BC what is that you
are completely nuts that's so
unrealistic but that's how we did it and
now we're worried that it's coming to an
end and it is coming to him because we
finally have robots that can do the
things that we've been using human
robots to do and I'm not saying we
should just get rid of those jobs
because jobs have all kinds of purposes
in people's lives and I'm not a big fan
of upî which says basically okay we give
up humans are useless so you know the
machines will feed them and house them
entertain them but that's all they're
good for now the benefits to me it's
hard to imagine just like we could not
imagine very well all the things we
would use the internet for I mean I
remember Berkeley computer science
faculty in the 80s sitting around at
lunch we knew more about networking than
almost anybody else but we still had
absolutely no idea what was the point of
being able to click on a link what's
that about we totally blew it and we
don't understand all the things that
superhuman AI could do for us I mean
Steve mentioned that we could do much
better science and I agree with that in
the book I visualized it as taking
various ideas like travel as a service
and extending that to everything as a
service so traveler service is a good
example if you think about going to
Australia 200 years ago you're talking
about a billion dollar proposition
probably 10 years thousands of people
80% chance of death
now I take out my cell phone I go tap
tap tap and now I'm in Australia
tomorrow and it's basically free
compared to what it used to be so that's
what I mean by as a service you want
something you just get superhuman AI
could make everything as a service so
think about the things that are
expensive and difficult or impossible
now like training a neurosurgeon or
building a railway to connect your rural
village to a nearby city so that people
can visit or trade or whatever but most
of developing world these things are
completely out of reach the health
budget of a lot of countries in Africa
is less than $10 per person per year so
the entire health budget of a country
would train one neurosurgeon in the US
so these things aren't rich but if you
take out
the humans then these services can
become effectively free they become
services like travel is today and that
would enable us to bring everyone on
earth up to the kind of living standard
that they might aspire to and if we can
figure out the resource constraints and
so on that would be a wonderful thing
now that's quite a beautiful picture of
the future there's a lot of existential
hope there the other side to existential
hope is existential risk now this is an
interesting subject which Steve and you
Stewart believe have disagreements about
so pivoting into this area and Steve you
can go first here do you believe that
human beings should we not go extinct in
the meantime will we build artificial
superintelligence
and does that pose an existential risk
to humanity yeah well I want record is
being skeptical of that scenario and
dubious about the value of putting a lot
of effort into worrying about it the
concept of super intelligence is itself
completely obscure and that in a lot of
discussions you can replace the word
super intelligence with magic or miracle
and the sentence would read just the
same you read about the AI system that
could duplicate brains in silicon that
can solve problems like war in the
Middle East or cure cancer and it's just
imagining a solution and just assuming
that the ability to bring it about will
exist not laying out what that
intelligence would consist of or even
what the solution to the problem might
look like so I find this concept of
super intelligence itself a dubious
extrapolation of a neck strap little
container like human to animal or
not-so-bright human to smart human I
don't think that there is a power called
intelligence such that if we compare a
squirrel with an octopus we can say well
imagine even more than that I'm quite
skeptical about the existential risk
scenarios they tend to come in two
varieties one of them is I think based
on a notion of a will to power that as
soon as you get an intelligence system
that it will inevitably want to dominate
and exploit often the analogy is we
humans have exploited or often
extinguished animals because we're
smarter than
so as soon as there is an artificial
system it's smarter than us it'll do to
ask what we did to Dodos or
technologically advanced civilizations
like Europeans the colonists and the
conquistadors subjugated and some ones
wiped out indigenous peoples and that's
what an AI system might do to us as one
variety of the scenario I think that
scenario confuses intelligence with
dominance or a will to power based on
the fact that in our species in Homo
sapiens they happen to come bundled
together because we came about through
the process of natural selection which
is a competitive process driven by
relative success at capturing scarce
resources ultimately in relative
reproductive success but there's no
reason that a system that is designed to
pursue a goal would have as its goal
domination and this goes back to our
earlier discussion that the ability to
achieve a goal is distinct from what the
goal is it just so happens that in
products of natural selection the goal
of winning in competition was the
process by which evolution be evolved
for an artifact that we design there's
just no reason that that would be true
this is sometimes called the orthogonal
of a thesis in discussions of
existential risk although it's just a
fancy schmancy way of referring to Humes
distinction between our goals and our
intelligence now I know that there is an
argument that says well wouldn't any
intelligence system have to maximize its
own survivability because if it's given
the goal of X well you can't achieve X
if you don't exist therefore as a sub
goal to achieving X you've got to
maximize your own survival at all costs
I think that's fallacious and it's
certainly not true that all complex
systems have to work toward their own
perpetuation my iPhone doesn't take any
steps to resist my dropping it into a
toilet or letting it run out of power
you could imagine it could be programmed
like a child's to wine and to cry and to
refuse to do what it's told to do as its
power level went down we wouldn't buy
one and we know in the natural world
there are plenty of living systems that
sacrifice their own longevity for other
goals like when it bees things.you their
barbs in its stinger are dislodged let
me be escaped killing the bee but
because the bee is program
to maximize the survivability of the
colony not itself it willingly
sacrifices itself so it is not true that
by definition an intelligent system is
going to maximize its power I think the
more common existential threat scenario
is not will to power but collateral
damage that if an AI system is given a
single goal what if it relentlessly
pursues it without consideration of side
effects including harm to us and there
are famous examples that I originally
thought or spoofs but were intended
seriously like giving a AI system the
goal of making as many paper clips as
possible and so it converts all
available matter into paper clips
including our own bodies putting aside
the fact that we don't need more
efficient paper clip manufacturing than
what we already have and the human
bodies are a pretty crummy source of
iron for paper clips the idea that we
could give an AI system the goal of
curing cancer and so will induce tumors
and all of us and conscripted into being
involuntary guinea pigs that give it a
goal of regulating the level of water
behind a dam and it might flat a town
not knowing that one of its goals is to
not drown an entire village a problem
with these scenarios is that they're
almost self refuting a assume that an
artifact would be designed with a single
goal which is just not true of even the
stupid artifacts that we live with when
we have a car we don't just design it
with a goal of going from A to B as fast
as possible we also install brakes and a
steering wheel and a muffler and a
catalytic converter and a lot of these
scenarios seem to presuppose both it is
the only a part of the designers that
would give a system control over the
infrastructure of the planet without
testing at first to see how it worked
and an idiocy on the part of the
allegedly intelligent system that would
pursue one goal regardless of all of the
other effects something that just does
not exist in any human artifact let
alone when it claims to be intelligent
giving an AI system one vaguely worded
sketchy goal and empowering it with
control over the entire infrastructure
of the planet without testing it
to me juicy so self-evident waiting
moronic that I don't particularly worry
that engineers have to be warned against
it I've quoted Stuart himself who in an
interview said no one talks about
building bridges that don't fall down
they just call it building bridges
likewise AI that avoids hideous things
like that is AI it's not AI with extra
safeguards
that's just what intelligence consists
of now let me just make one other
comment because you could say well even
if the odds are small the damage could
be so catastrophic that it is worth our
concern I think there are downsides to
worrying about existential risk one of
them is the possible stigmatization and
abandonment of helpful technology
Stewart mentioned the example from
nuclear power which I considered to be a
catastrophe that we don't roll out
nuclear power the way that France did
there was the spectacular bungling of
Chernobyl but on top of that there was
also the fairly trivial accident at
Three Mile Island in the United States
which of course killed no one but
because of a dread of Technology we
prematurely abandoned something that
really could have been our salvation
genetically modified organisms or
another example something with
spectacular benefits where there's been
enough filling of fear that they have
been outlawed depriving us as the
spectacular benefits of Greater
ecological sustainability human
nutrition less use of water and
pesticides and so on there's also other
downsides of what I think of as
groundless worries about exotic
hypothetical existential risks there is
some reasoning in the existential risk
community and in the so called
rationality community that since the
harm of extinguishing the species is
basically infinite the probabilities no
longer matter because by expected
utility calculation if you multiply
infinity or even if you multiply in a
very large number of potential
defendants of humans before the Sun
expands in some of these scenarios even
taking you to account wild scenarios
like multiplying the number of
consciousnesses by uploading
connected home to the cloud or
colonizing other solar systems well even
an easy easy infinitesimal probability
of extinction is catastrophic and we
should worry about it the problem of
course is that that argument could apply
to any nonzero scenario maybe there'll
be evolution of toxic killer gerbils
that will nibble everyone to death and
if I say that's preposterous you say
well even if the probability is very
very small since the harm of extinction
is so great
we shouldn't devote some brainpower to
that scenario I do fear the moral hazard
of human intellect being absorbed in
this free-for-all than any risk if you
imagine that it's an existential could
justify any amount of expenditure by
this what I consider a elicit expected
utility calculation that smart people
will be absorbed into what might be a
fruitless pursuit compared to areas
where we really do need application of
human brain power in climate in
prevention of nuclear war prevention of
pandemics given that those are real
risks that no one denies that those are
risks we haven't solved any of them
together with other things like say
preventing and curing Alzheimer's
disease I wonder if the infinitesimal
probability times infinite harm is the
right way of allocating our intellectual
capital you're sure you want to react to
those points yeah there's a lot to react
to you and I'm tempted to start at the
end and work back and just ask well if
we were spending hundreds of billions of
dollars a year to breed billions of
toxic killer gerbils wouldn't you ask
people if that was a good idea before
dismissing any reason to be concerned
about it if that's what we were actually
investing in creating I don't buy the
analogy between AI and toxic killer
gerbils in any shape or form but
I will go back to the beginning and we
began by talking about feasibility and
Steve argues I think primarily that it's
not even meaningful that we could create
superhuman levels of intelligence that
there isn't a single continuum and yes
there isn't a single continuum but there
doesn't have to be a single continuum
when people say one person is more
intelligent than another or one species
is more intelligent than other it's not
a scientific statement that there's a
single scalar on which species one
exceeds species two they are talking in
broad-brush so when we say humans are
more intelligent than chimpanzees that's
probably a reasonable thing to say but
there are clearly dimensions of
intelligence who are actually
chimpanzees are more intelligent than
humans for example short-term memory a
chimpanzee once they get what a digit is
they can learn 20 digit telephone
numbers at the drop of a hat and humans
can't do that clearly there's dimensions
on which chimpanzee intelligence on
averages are will be better than human
but nonetheless when you look at which
species would you rather be right now
the chimpanzees don't have much of a
chance against the humans I think that
there is a meaningful motion of
generality of intelligence and one way
to think about it is to take a
decision-making scenario where we
already understand how to produce very
effective decisions and then ask how is
that decision scenario restricted and
what happens when we relaxed the
restrictions and figure out how to
maintain the same what's a superhuman
quality of decision-making so if you
look at go plane it's clear that the
humans have been left far behind so it's
not unreasonable to ask just as the
machines wipe the floor with humans on
the go board and the chessboard and now
on the Starcraft board and lots of other
boards could you take that and transfer
that into the real world where we make
decisions of all kinds the difference
between the go board in the real world
is pretty dramatic and that's why we've
had lots of success on the go board and
not so much in the real world
first thing is that the NGO board is
fully observable you can see the entire
state of the world that matters and of
course in the real world there's lots of
stuff you don't see and don't know some
of it you can infer by accumulating
information over time what we call state
estimation but that turns out to be
quite difficult problem another thing is
that we know all the rules ago and of
course in the real world you don't know
all the rules you have to learn a lot as
you go along another thing about the go
board is that despite the fact that we
think of it as really complicated it's
incredibly simple compared to the real
world at any given time on the go board
there's a couple of hundred legal moves
and the game lasts for a couple under
moves and if you said well what are the
analogous primitive actions in the real
world for a human being well we have 600
muscles and we can actuate them maybe
about 10 times per second each your
brain probably isn't able to do that but
physically that's what could be your
action space and so you actually have
been a far greater action space and you
also are talking about we often make
plans that last for many years which is
literally trillions of primitive actions
in terms of muscle activations now we
don't plan those all out in detail but
we function on those kinds of timescales
those are some of the ways that go and
real-world differ and what we do in AI
is we don't say ok I don't go now I'm
gonna work on suicide go and now I'm
going to work on chess for three Queens
what we try to do is extract the general
lessons ok we now understand fairly well
how to handle that whole class of
problems can we relax the assumptions
these basic qualitative assumptions
about the nature of the problem and if
you relax all the ones that I listed and
probably a couple more they've got
you're getting towards systems that can
function at a superhuman level in the
real world assuming that you figure out
how to deal with all those issues so
just as we find ourselves flummoxed by
the Meuse that the AI system makes on
the go board if you're a general and
you're up against an AI system that's
controlling or coming up with the
decision making plans or the other side
you might find yourself omix than
everything you try the machine is
already anticipated and put in place
something that will prevent your plan
from succeeding
the pace of warfare will be beyond
anything humans have ever contemplated
right so they won't even have time to
think just as the Rockies were not used
to the rate of decision-making of the US
Army in the first Gulf War and they
couldn't do anything they were literally
paralyzed and just step by step by step
the Allied forces were able to take them
apart because they couldn't respond
within the timescales of the Allied
forces who were operating so it would be
kind of like that if you were a human
general if you were human CEO and your
competitor company is organized and run
by AI systems you'd be in the same kind
of situation so it's entirely
conceivable I'm not necessarily
implausible but conceivable that we can
create real-world decision-making
capabilities that exceed those of humans
across the board so that this notion of
generality I think it is something that
still needs to be worked out most
definitions of generality that people
come up with end up saying well you know
humans are general because they can do
all the things that humans can do which
is sort of a tautology but nonetheless
it's interesting that when you think
about all the jobs you know dr.
carpenter advertising sales
representative most normally functioning
people could do most of those jobs at
least to some reasonable level so we are
incredibly flexible compared to current
AI systems there is progress on
achieving generality but there's a long
way to go I'm certainly not one of those
who says that super intelligent AI is
imminent that's why we need to worry and
in fact I'm probably more conservative
if you want to appeal to what most
expert AI people think most expert AI
people think that we will have something
that's reasonably described as super
intelligent AI sooner than I do
so most people think sometime in the
middle of the century turns out that
Asian AI researchers particularly in
China more optimistic so they think
twenty years people in the US and Europe
maybe more like 40 years I would be
reasonably confident saying by the end
of the century I think Nick Bostrom is
in about the same place he's also more
conservative and the average expert AI
researcher there are major breakthroughs
that have to happen but the massive
investment that's taking place the info
of incredibly smart people into the
field these things suggest that those
breakthroughs will probably take place
by the time skills very hard to say and
when we think about the risks I would
say Steve is really putting up one straw
man after another and then locking it
down so for example the paperclip
argument is not a scenario that Nick
Bostrom thinks is one of the more likely
ways for the human race to end it's a
philosophical thought experiment
intended to illustrate a point
and the point is incontrovertible and I
don't think Steve disagrees with it so
let's not use the word intelligent
because I think Steve here is using the
word intelligent to mean always behaves
in whatever way we think we wish that it
would behave well of course if you
define intelligence that way then there
isn't an issue the question is how do we
create any such thing and the ways we
have right now of creating any such
thing fall under the standard model
which I described earlier that we set up
let's call it a super optimizer and then
we give it an objective and then off it
go that he's describing what happens
when you give a super optimizer the
wrong goal and he's not saying yes of
course we should give it wrong goals and
he's using this to illustrate what
happens when you give it even what seems
to be innocuous so he's trying to convey
the idea that we are not very good at
judging the consequences of seemingly
innocuous goals you know my example of
curing cancer right I mean curing cancer
yeah of course that's a good goal to
give to an AI system but the point is if
that's the only goal you get to the AI
system then all these weird things
happen because that's the nature of
super optimizing that's the nature of
the standard model of AI and this is I
think the main point being made is not
that no matter what we do AI is going to
get us it's that given our current
understanding and given hundreds of
billions of dollars are being invested
into that current understanding then
here is a failure mode and it's
reasonable to point that out just as if
you're a nuclear engineer you say look
everyone is designing these reactors in
this way all of you are doing this oh
look there's this failure mode that's a
reasonable thing to point out I think
it's a reasonable task are these strong
men or
they're real people that have to be
warned of this failure mode I picked
some examples of course from your book
because I was mindful of not picking a
strawman and giving people tumors in
order to cure cancer of course it's your
example you seem to be using this as a
warning against definition of
intelligence as super optimizing a
single goal but that just strikes me as
so self-evidently unintelligent or we
have multiple goals there's a whole
field of multi attribute utility theory
that's been going now for more than 50
years of course we understand that when
we look at even the design of the
algorithms that uber uses to get you to
the airport
they take into account multiple goals
but the point is the same argument
applies if you operate in the standard
model when you add in the multiple goals
unless you're able to be sure that you
have completely and correctly captured
all the things we care about under all
conceivable and inconceivable because I
think one of the things about super
intelligent AI systems they will come up
with by human standards inconceivable
forms of action we cannot guarantee that
and this is the point
so you could say multiple goals but
multiple goals are just a single goal
right they add up to the ability to rank
futures and the question is is that
ability to rank futures fully aligned
with what humans want their futures to
be like and the answer is inevitably
know we are inevitably going to leave
things out so even if you have a
thousand terms in the objective function
there's probably another million that
you ought to have included that you
didn't think because it never occurred
to you so for example you can go out and
find lists of important things that
human beings care about this is sort of
the whole values community human
development community Maslow hierarchy
all of those things your people do make
whole lists of things trying to build up
a picture of very roughly what is the
human utility function after all but
invariably those lists just refer to
things that are usually a subject of
discussion among humans about you know
do we spend money on schools or
hospitals or whatever it might be on
that list you will not find the color of
the sky because no one know humans right
now are thinking about oh should we
change the sky
the orange with pink stripes but if
someone did change this color this guy
can bet you a lot of people would be
really upset about it and so invariably
we fail to include many many criteria in
whatever lists of objectives you might
come up with when you do that what
happens is that the optimizer will take
advantage of those dimensions of freedom
and typically actually under fairly
general algebraic conditions will set
them to extreme values because that
gives you better optimization on the
things that are in the list of goals so
the argument is that within the standard
model which a bears some responsibility
for because it's the way we wrote the
first three editions of the textbook
within the standard model further
progress nai could lead to increasing
problems of control and it's not because
there's any will to dominance I don't
know of any serious thinkers in the
at-risk community who think that that's
the problem
that's another straw man when you finish
I do have some responses to that yeah
the argument is not that we
automatically build in because we will
want our assistance to be alpha males or
anything like that
I think Stevo mohandro has put it fairly
clearly in so on Pizza billion papers
that the behavior of a super optimizer
given any finite list of goals is going
to include efforts to maximize its
computational resources and other
resources that will help it achieve the
objectives that we do specify and you
could put in something saying well and
don't spend any money or don't do this
and don't do that don't do the other but
the same structure of the argument is
going to apply we can reduce the risk by
adding more and more stuff into the
explicit objectives but I think the
argument making in the book is that
that's just a completely broken way to
design AI systems
the meta argument is that if we don't
talk about the failure modes we won't be
able to address them so actually I think
that Steve and I don't disagree about
the plausible future evolution I don't
think it's particularly plausible if I
was going into forecast mode so just
betting on the future saying what's the
probability that this thing will happen
well that thing will happen I don't
think it's particularly plausible that
we will be destroyed by super
intelligent AI there are several reasons
but I don't think that's going to occur
because we would probably get some early
warnings of it and if we couldn't figure
out how to prevent it we would probably
put very strong restrictions on further
development or we would figure out how
to actually make it provably safe and
beneficial but you can't have that
discussion unless you talk about the
failure modes just like in nuclear
safety it's not against the rules to
raise possible failure modes like what
if this molten sodium that you're
proposing should flow around all these
pipes what if it ever came into contact
with the water that's on the turbine
side of the system wouldn't you have a
massive explosion which could rip off
the containment and so on so it's not
exactly what happened in general but not
so dissimilar and of course that's what
they do so this culture of safety that
Steve talks about consists exactly of
this people saying look if you design
things that way these terrible things
are going to happen so don't design
things that way you design things this
way and this is a process that we are
going through in the AI community right
now and I have to say I just actually
was reading a letter from one of my very
senior colleagues former president of to
play AI who said five years ago everyone
thought Stuart was nuts but - it was
right these risks have to be taken
seriously and we all owe him a great
debt for bringing it within the AI
community so that we can start to
address it and I don't think I invented
these risks and I was just in a chance
position that I had two years as a
radical to think about the future of the
field and to read some of the things
that others had already written about
the field from the outside so my sense
is that Steve and I are kind of the
glass half-full glass of empty in terms
of our forecast we think on the whole
the weather tomorrow is likely to be
sunny I think we disagree on how to make
sure that it's sunny I really do think
that the problem of creating provably
beneficial AI by which I mean that no
matter how powerful the AI system is we
remain in power we have power over it
forever but we never lose control that's
a big ask and the idea that we could
follow that problem without even
mentioning it without even talking about
it and without even pointing out why
it's difficult and why it's important
that's not the culture of safety that
sort of more like the culture of the
Communist Party committee in Ginobili
that simply continued to assert that
nothing bad was happening obviously I'm
all in favor of the safety mindset of
engineering that is you test the system
before you implement it you try to
anticipate the failure modes but a lot
of this discussion particularly things
like flooding a town to control the
water level or turning humans into
voluntary guinea pigs or maximizing
happiness by injecting everyone with a
drip of antidepressants a striking is so
far from reasonable failure bodes that
they're not part of a ordinary
engineering effort to ensure safety
particularly when they are coupled with
the term existential may we not this is
just a system that will make an error
available in human species that is very
different from not plugging in an AI
system until you've tested it to find
out whether it fails and the notion of a
super optimizer given in some of these
thought experiments maybe we agree here
that it's just so unintelligent to give
us this to one goal that done no one
will actually empower it but if I wasn't
saying we give it one go I'm saying
however many goals we give it that's
equivalent to giving it a ranking over
futures so the idea of single goal of us
is multi goal is a complete red herring
but as you go down the tail of possible
risks you're getting into potentially
infinitesimal risks in which case there
is no system conceivable or existing
that will have zero risk of every
possibility if we could do that if we
had some serious theory by which we
could say okay we've got within epsilon
of the true human
ranking over futures I think that's very
hard to do we literally do not have a
clue how and the purpose of these
examples is actually to dismiss the idea
that this has a simple solution so
people want to dismiss the idea of risk
by saying oh we'll just give the AI
system such-and-such objective and then
the failure mode goes away and
everything's cool and then people say oh
but no if you look if you give it the
objective that everyone should be happy
then here's a solution that the AI
system could find that clearly we
wouldn't want those protesters our lead
actually to deeper questioning what do
we really mean by happy we don't just
mean pleasure as measured by the
pleasure center in the brain and the
same arguments happened in moral
philosophy so no one is accusing GE
Moore of being a naive idiot because he
objected to a pleasure maximization
definition of what is a good moral
decision to make he was making an
important philosophical point and I
don't think we should dismiss that same
point when it's made in the context of
designing objectives her AI systems
however I don't think we have to worry
about a universally empowered AI system
has just given the goal of maximizing
human happiness that's the straw man and
particularly that in the scenarios that
are designed to so worry such as
conscripting the entire human race is
involuntary guinea pigs and cancer
experiments even if there is an epsilon
that we can't go below in laying out
possible risks doesn't strike me that
that's within the epsilon
these are strike me more as exercises of
human imagination
assuming a ridiculous waste simplified
system that's given one goal what could
go wrong well yeah stuff could go wrong
but is that really what's going to face
us when it comes to actual AI systems
that have some hope of being implemented
naturally we ought to test the living
daylights out of any system before we
give it control over anything and that's
of course the building bridges that
don't fall down and standard safety
advocate engineering but I'm not sure
that the more exotic scenarios based on
incredibly stupid ideas for any AI
systems like give it the goal of
maximize
human happiness is going to be the root
gives off a very I okay so let me say
once again right that the one goal
versus multiple goal thing is a red
herring in if you think it's so easy to
specify the goal correctly perhaps your
next paper will write it out then we'll
say okay that's not a storm and this is
Eve Pinker's suggestion of what the
objective should be for the super
intelligent AI system and then for
people who love doing these things
horribly nick bostrom and others will
find ways of failing so the idea that we
could just test before deploying
something that is significantly more
powerful than human beings or even the
human race combined that's a pretty
optimistic idea we're not even able to
test ordinary software systems right now
so test generation is one of the
effective methods used in software
engineering but it has many many known
failure cases for real-world examples
including multiplication Intel's Pentium
chip was tested with billions of
examples of multiplication but it failed
to uncover a bug in the multiplication
circuitry which caused it to produce
incorrect results in some cases and so
we have a technology of formal
verification which would have uncovered
that error but particularly in the u.s.
there's a culture that somewhat opposed
a using formal verification in software
design less so in hardware design
nowadays partly because of the Pentium
era but still in software formal
verification is considered very
difficult and very European and not
something we do and this is far harder
than that because software verification
typically is thinking only about
correctness of software in an internal
sense that what happens inside the
algorithm between the inputs and outputs
meet some specification what we want
here is that the combination of the
algorithm and the world evolves in ways
that we are certain to be pleased about
and that's a much harder kind of thing
control theory has that view of what
they mean by verification and they're
able to do very simple linear quadratic
regulator x' and a few other examples
and beyond that they get stuck and so I
actually think that the testing is
probably neither feasible I mean not
saying we shouldn't do it but it's going
to be
extremely hard to get any kind of
confidence from testing because you're
really asking can you simulate the
entire world and all the ways the system
could use the world to bring about the
objective however complicated and
however multifaceted that objective is
it's probably going to be the wrong one
so I've proposed a not completely
different but a generalized form of AI
that knows that it doesn't know what the
real objectives are it knows it doesn't
know how humans ranked possible futures
and that changes the way it behaves but
that also has failure modes one of them
being the plasticity of human preference
rankings over the future and how do you
prevent the AI system from taking
advantage of that plasticity you can't
prevent it completely because anything
it does is going to have some effect on
human preferences but the question is
what constitutes reasonable
modifications of human preferences and
what constitutes unreasonable ones we
don't know the answer to that so there
are many many really difficult research
problems that we have to overcome for
the research agenda that I'm proposing
to have a chance of success not that
optimistic that this is an easy or
straightforward problem to solve and I
think we can only solve it if we go
outside the conceptual framework that AI
has worked in for the last 70 years
well yes certainly if the conceptual
framework is optimizing terms single or
small that list of goals but note that
you've also given a number of arguments
why a lot of the fantasies of super
intelligence are unlikely to come about
precisely because the near miraculous
powers that are assumed for the
intelligence that will smart us that
will solve problems including the
problem of augmenting its own
intelligence that will would defeat all
of our attempts to control it are
themselves liable to exactly the
vulnerabilities that would make it
untestable namely we can't take into
account the fantastically chaotic and
unpredictable reactions of humans we
can't program in a system that has
complete knowledge of the physical
universe without allowing it to do the
equivalent of experiments and to acquire
empirical knowledge at a rate determined
by the world so just the infirmities and
vulnerabilities that mean that we can't
explore
the entire space of behavior of one of
these systems in advance is the reason
that it's not going to be super
intelligent in the way that these
scenarios outline and indeed that's a
reason not to empower any system that
aspires toward super intelligence or
that we might think of as super
intelligent precisely because that
itself is not likely to exist and it's
likely to display in various forms of
error and stupidity I would agree that
some of the concerns that you might see
in the extra risk community are we say
non-physical so the idea that a system
could predict the next hundred years and
your entire life in such detail that a
hundred years ago it knew what you were
going to be saying at a particular milli
second hundred years in the future this
is obviously complete nonsense I don't
think we need to be too concerned about
that as a serious question whether it's
a four experiment that sheds light on
fundamental questions in decision theory
like the Newcomb problems is another
issue that we don't have to get into but
we can't solve the problem by saying
well super intelligence of the kind that
could lead to significant global
consequences could not possibly exist
and actually I kind of like Danny Hillis
his argument which says that actually no
it already does exist and it already has
any is having significant global
consequences and his example is to view
let's say the fossil fuel industry as if
it were an AI system and I think this is
an interesting line of thought because
what he's saying basically and other
people have said similar things is that
you should think of a corporation as if
it's an algorithm in its maximizing a
poorly designed objective which you
might say is some discounted stream of
quarterly profits or whatever and it
really is doing it in a way that's
oblivious to lots of other concerns of
the human race and it has outwitted the
rest of the human race so we might all
think well of course we know that what
is trying to do is wrong and because we
all know the right answer but in fact
we've lost and we should have pointed
out a hundred years ago that there is
this risk and it needs to be taken
seriously and it was people did pointed
out a hundred years ago but no one took
them seriously and this is what happened
so I think we have actually fairly good
example that this type of thing the
optimization of objectives ignoring
externalities as the economists would
point out by super-intelligent entities
and in some sense the fossil fuel
industry outwitted us because whatever
organizational structures allow large
groups of humans to generate effective
complex behaviors in the real world and
develop complex plans it operates in
some ways like a super intelligent
entity just like we were able to put a
person on the moon because of the
combined effect of many human intellects
working together but each of those
humans in the fossil fuel industry is a
piece of an algorithm if you like and
their own individual preferences about
the future don't count for much and in
fact they get molded by their role
within the corporation so I think in
some ways you already have an existence
proof that a concern is real clearly we
ought to anticipate reasonable risks and
attempt to mitigate them but the crucial
thing is they have to be calibrated
against what we know taking into account
our own ignorance it will be very easy
to go off chasing false stories such as
running out of petroleum which was the
big worry in the nineteen seventies now
the problem is too much not too little
overpopulation genetically modified
organisms it's easy to sow fear about
the wrong risks and my concern about the
existential risk of AI is that above and
beyond the ordinary concern with the
safety of any system that's given
control over the physical universe we
may be by spinning out
exotic scenarios misallocating where our
concern really ought to be exactly in
problems like climate change as opposed
to say in voluntary conscription in
cancer experiments all right so wrapping
up here do you guys have final
statements that you'd like to say just
if you felt like we just said didn't
fully capture what you want to end on on
this issue of AI existential risk yeah
so despite our disagreements most about
my assessment of pay I think agrees with
Stewart's assessment I personally don't
think that the adjective existential is
helpful in ordinary concerns over safety
which we are
I think there are tremendous potential
benefits to AI that we ought to seek at
the same time as we anticipate the
reasonable risks and take every effort
to mitigate them yeah I mean it's hard
to disagree that we should focus on the
reasonable risks the question is whether
you think that the hundreds of billions
of dollars that are being invested into
AI research will produce systems that
can have potentially global consequences
and to me it seems self-evident that it
can and we can look at even simple
machine learning algorithms like the
content selection algorithms in social
media because those algorithms interact
with humans for hours every day and
dictate what literally billions of
people see and read every day they are
having substantial global impact already
and they're very very simple they don't
know that human beings exist at all but
they still learn to manipulate our
brains to optimize the objective and I
had a very interesting little Facebook
exchange with Yamla kun and at some
point in the argument Yan said something
quite similar to something Steve said
earlier he said there's really no risk
you'd have to be extremely stupid to put
an incorrect objective into a powerful
system and then deploy it on a global
scale and I said well you mean like
optimizing click-through and he said you
know Facebook stopped using clickthrough
years ago and I said well why was that
he said because it was the incorrect
objective so you did put an incorrect
objective into a powerful system
deployed on a global scale what does
that say about Facebook so I think just
as you might have said and in fact the
nuclear industry did say it's perfectly
safe nothing can go wrong we're the
experts we understand safety we
understand everything
nonetheless we had two noble we had
Fukushima and actually I think there's
an argument to be made the despite the
massive environmental costs of forgoing
nuclear power that countries like
Germany Italy Spain and probably a bunch
of others are in the process of actually
deciding that we need to phase out
nuclear power because even though
theoretically it's possible to develop
and operate completely safe nuclear
our systems it's beyond our capabilities
and the evidence is there you know you
might have argued that while Russia is
corrupt its technology was not as great
as it should have been they couple of
quarters but you can't argue that the
Japanese nuclear industry was
unsophisticated or unconcerned with
safety but they still fail and so I
think voters in those countries who said
we don't want nuclear power because we
just don't want to be in that situation
even if we have the engineers making our
best efforts these kinds of
considerations suggest that we do need
to pay very careful attention I'm not
saying we should stop working on climate
change but you know when we invented
synthetic biology we said okay we better
think about how do we prevent the
creation of disease or new disease
organisms that could produce pandemics
and we took steps people bent a lot of
time thinking about safety mechanisms
for those devices we have to do the same
thing for AI all right Stuart Stephen
thanks so much I've learned a ton of
stuff today if listeners want to follow
you or look into your work where's the
best place to do that we'll start with
you Stephen even Pinker calm as they
thinker on Twitter and Stewart so you
can google me I don't really have a
website or social media activity but the
book human compatible which was
published last October by Viking in the
US and penguin in the UK and it's being
translated into lots of languages I
think that captures my view is pretty
well all right thanks so much for coming
on and yeah I was a pleasure speaking
thanks very much Lucas for hosting it
Thank You Stuart for the dialogue it was
great fun Steve I look forward to doing
it again me too
if you enjoyed this podcast please
subscribe give it a like or share it on
your preferred social media platform
we'll be back again soon with another
episode in the AI alignment series
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you